it was a car accident nothing
particularly remarkable but fatal
nonetheless he left behind a wife and
children it was however painless death
the EMTs tried their best to save you
but to no avail your body was utterly
shattered you were better off trust me
wait what happened you asked where am I
you died I said matter-of-factly my
appointments in Wales there was a truck
and it was hidden I I died
yep you died but there's no need to feel
bad about it everyone dies I said you
looked around there was nothing less
just you and me what is this place you
asked is this the afterlife more or less
I said are you God yes I replied I'm God
my kids my wife you said what about them
will they be okay and that's what I like
to see I said you just died and your
main concern is for your family that's
good stuff right there you look to me
with fascination to you I didn't look
like a god I just look like some man
some vague authority figure more of a
Grammar School teacher than the Almighty
don't worry I said they'll be fine your
kids will remember you as perfect in
every way they didn't have time to grow
contempt for you
your wife will cry on the outside but
she will be secretly relieved to be fair
your marriage was falling apart and if
it's any consolation she'll feel very
guilty for feeling relieved so what
happens now
do I go to heaven or hell neither I said
you'll be reincarnated uh you said so
the Hindus were right all of the regions
are right in their own way I said walk
with me
you followed me along as we strolled in
the void where are we going nowhere in
particular I said it's just nice to walk
while we talk so what's the point then
you asked when I get reborn I'll just be
a blank slate right a baby so all of my
experiences and everything I did in this
life won't matter
not so I said you have within you all of
the knowledge and experiences of your
past lives you just don't remember them
right now I stopped walking and I took
you by the shoulders your soul is more
magnificent beautiful and gigantic than
you could possibly imagine a human mind
can only contain a fraction of what you
are it's like sticking your finger in a
glass of water to see if it's hot or
cold you put a tiny part of yourself
into the vessel and when you bring it
back you've gained all the experiences
it had you've been a human for the last
34 years
so you haven't stretched out and felt
your entire consciousness yet if we hang
out here for longer you'd sort remember
in everything but there's no point in
doing that in between each life how many
times have I been reincarnated Oh
lots and lots and into lots of different
lives I said this time you'll be a
Chinese peasant girl in the year 540 ad
wait what you stammered you're sending
me back in time well I guess technically
time as you know it only exists in your
universe things are different why come
from and where exactly do you come from
you pondered oh sure I explained I come
from somewhere somewhere else and there
are others like me I know you want to
know more but you wouldn't understand oh
you said a little letdown but wait if I
get reincarnated to other places in time
could I interact with myself at the same
point sure it happens all the time and
with both lives only aware of their own
time span you don't even know it's
happening so what's the point of it all
seriously
I asked you'll seriously asking me the
meaning of life isn't that a little
cliche well it's a reasonable question
you persisted I looked into your eye the
reason I made this entire universe is
for you to mature
you mean mankind you want us to mature
no just you I made this entire universe
for you with each life you grow and
mature and become a greater larger
intellect
what about everyone else there is no one
else I said in this universe there is
you and me you stared at me blankly but
all of the people back on earth they're
all you different incarnations of you
wait I'm everyone yes now you're getting
it I said what congratulatory slap on
the back I'm every human that's ever
lived or who will ever live so I'm
Abraham Lincoln and you're also John
Wilkes Booth I added I'm Hitler and
you're the millions he killed I'm Jesus
and you are everyone who followed him
you fell silent
every time you victimized someone I said
you were victimizing yourself every act
of kindness you've done you've done to
yourself every happy and sad moment ever
experienced by human was or will be
experienced by you why you asked me why
do all of this because someday you will
become like me because that is what you
are you are one of my kind you are my
child so you're saying that I'm a god no
not yet your fetus you're still growing
once you've lived every human life
throughout time you will have grown
enough to be born so the entire universe
is just an egg of sorts I answered now
it is time for you to move on to your
next life and with that I sent you on
your way